[Music]
while tom cruise can currently be seen
in theaters with top gun maverick many
fans are eagerly awaiting mission
impossible seven almost four years have
passed since the last installment and we
still need to wait more than a year for
the release of the next part in today's
original we are going to present you
with a first overview of the upcoming
blockbuster and talk about all the
information that is known so far after
that you will definitely be up to date
on the storyline the cast the production
and the first trailer so please enjoy a
new video
let's first briefly recap the storyline
of the previous movies the main focus is
on ethan hunt an agent of the so-called
impossible missions force or imf for
short this is a fictional use government
institution and with its highly
specialized team carries out only the
most difficult of missions in the first
installment ethan hunt's entire team is
seemingly wiped out as it eventually
turns out his mentor jim phelps faked
his own death merely to sell secret
documents to the highest bidder han
succeeds in finally avenging his team
and killing jim phelps in the second
part ethan hunt is seen traveling around
the world as a loner unfortunately his
vacation is interrupted by a call from
the imf as the next mission is already
expecting the agent this time he must
track down a harmful virus in the
possession of the terrorists on ambrose
the villain's plan is to release the
extremely lethal virus and then make
money by selling the cure needless to
say hunt manages to defeat ambrose
thereby saving the lives of millions of
people mission impossible 3 first shows
how agent han has retired from active
duty in order to use his expertise to
train new recruits however the normal
life he hopes to have with his wife
julia is abruptly disrupted by the
capture of his trainee lindsay while
trying to rescue her she tragically dies
and that leaves hunt with a new mission
which is to hunt down own davian the
black marketeer behind the incident
davian however manages to get ahead of
hunt and abducts his wife after a
nerve-wracking showdown he's able to
dispose of davian and save his wife by
the time of the fourth part a few years
have passed and hunt has decided to fake
the death of his wife since otherwise
she would be permanently targeted this
time he finds himself on a mission in
russia more precisely in the kremlin
there he is supposed to obtain
information about the arms dealer kurt
hendricks in the course of the mission
the kremlin is destroyed and used
government is held accountable by the
russians left on his own once again hun
tracks down hendricks while he himself
is forced into hiding due to the
unfolding events he's finally successful
in tracing the nuclear terrorist
preventing a third world war as well as
dealing with a new clue that leads to an
international crime ring called the
syndicate the penultimate film opens
with a scheme by the syndicate posing as
hunt's employer the imf hund is captured
and can only escape with the help of the
mysterious syndicate member elsa faust
she later reveals herself to be an mi6
agent and they both discover that this
syndicate was formed by mi6 chief athley
hunt and thus do their utmost to destroy
the syndicate from within in which they
succeed
the latest installment in this series is
mission impossible fallout released in
2018 in which ethan hunt and his team
are challenged with a race against the
clock once again they must prevent a
nuclear attack this time hunt and his
team are after arms dealer john lark in
addition to reuniting with his ex-wife
julia and her new husband eric he learns
that said john lark is none other than
hunt's initial colleague august walker
who has an agenda of his own after the
nail-biting helicopter shout out hunt
again holds the upper hand in this movie
and kills walker
after six movies the question arises as
to what the plot of the upcoming mission
impossible dead reckoning part 1 will
look like as usual with the franchise
little is revealed about the exact
storyline beforehand so our best clue is
the first trailer which was released at
the end of may in the barely 2 minute
long piece of action we see some
well-known faces including ethan hunt's
imf team consisting of ilsa benji and
luther clearly more exciting though is
the reunion between hunt and former imf
chief eugene kittridge the two last met
in the very first mission impossible
film and that was no less than 26 years
ago even then kittrich was wary of ethan
hunt and although hunt was able to clear
his name kid rich vanished from the
movie series altogether in the trailer
scene the two again seem to have a
rather strained relationship the former
imf director confronts hunt with a
question whether his loyalty is to the
us government or to his personal ideals
a further indication of a conflict
between hunt and the imf can be found in
the scene in which kidridge and an older
men sit across from each other in what
maybe ethan hunt in disguise the latter
throws two gas bombs into the room
knocking everyone unconscious about
himself in kittridge this could be a
sign that the imf is once again engaged
in dubious schemes and it appears to be
the only way han can have an undisturbed
talk with the imf official another
storyline will be the relationship
between hunt and elsa faust the tough
female agent has been an integral part
of the film series since mission
impossible 5 rogue nation and has also
been a potential love interest for the
main character ever since in the trailer
we see the two of them happily embracing
but also some sequences where they can
be spotted with an eye patch and blonde
hair also in one scene she seems to have
a heated argument with hunt suggesting a
volatile relationship between the two
further she wears a cross-like key
around her neck this could be an
important element in the course of the
film since the key appears numerous
times in the trailer another important
part seems to be given to the character
grace we see her for example during a
high-speed pursuit in rome and it is not
quite clear whose side the new character
is on she was described as a destructive
force of nature by director christopher
mcquarrie in an interview which doesn't
sound like a cutting hero figure to us
two villains will probably be played by
actors palm clementine and s.i morales
and roles yet unknown clementi seems to
be a kind of assassin who pursues hunt
and grace in one scene for example she
is also extremely agile and can
effortlessly fight multiple enemies at
once in some way we think she works for
morales figure who is presumably the
main villain he is also very skilled
with stabbing weapons and many speculate
that he will seriously injure or even
kill ilsa fostering the course of the
film to provoke ethan hunt's vengeance
who knows perhaps this will be the
cliffhanger for part 8. after all the
title edition part 1 of mission
impossible 7 strongly suggests that the
two movies will be closely connected as
you can see the trailer reveals a
healthy mix between familiar characters
and new ones and at the same time
manages not to give too much away still
the footage shown leaves enough
questions that can be addressed in more
detail either by further information or
a new trailer
truth be told the many plot twists and
story lines that pop up regularly
throughout the film series are only part
of the movie experience equally
important to many fans are the stunts
that have always been the signature
feature of mission impossible as well as
tom cruise we are particularly looking
forward to two scenes that are hinted at
in the trailer in one we see tom cruise
and the bad guy battling on top of a
crane which is a nice reference to the
very first part we are certain that the
train sequence will conclude the film
and decide the further plot of part 8.
another stunt may not be as plot
relevant as the train shot but it is all
the more impressive we're talking about
tom cruise's motorcycle stunt which made
headlines long before the trailer was
released we see how the soon 60 year old
crew speeds over the precipice and saves
himself with a parachute at the very
last second actually not much of a
surprise anymore with the franchise of
course there was no stunned duel in
action here either just tom cruise
himself allegedly he performed over 13
000 motocross jumps and over 500
parachute jumps in preparation as we are
told the actor had only one attempt to
make the scene work a small mistake on
the motorcycle or parachute could have
had disastrous consequences thus it is
all the more remarkable that he wanted
to perform the stun himself what some
may have missed he is wearing the same
outfit there as in the scene with a
train
will he actually land on the train in
style with his parachute we can't wait
to find out
after we have already mentioned some of
the names and characters we will now
list the actors who are involved in
mission impossible dead reckoning part
1. of course the familiar team of heroes
once again consists of tom cruise as
ethan hunt rebecca ferguson as ilsa
faust simon pagas benji dunn and wing
rhames as luther's stickle we are also
happy to see the return of henry cherny
who will play the aforementioned eugene
kid rich one more time on the villain
side there's also an old familiar face
and that is vanessa kirby as white widow
new to the cast rsi morales as this
still nameless antagonist haley and
willis grace along with shea wiggum as
jasper bricks who will be following
ethan hunt in part seven and eight among
the actress with the still unknown roles
are palm clementiev carrie elvis indira
varma margates and rob delaney
lastly let's talk about the production
of the movie and some facts worth
mentioning what many fans probably
remember most is the repeated
postponement of the start of shooting
along with the release date as a result
of the pandemic in the end filming ended
up lasting from september 6 2020 to
september 2021 which was mainly due to
more rigorous regulations and contact
restrictions in addition there were loud
protests regarding a scene set in
switzerland there they plan on filming a
train crossing a bridge that had
previously been blown up however the
swiss government did not grant
permission for this as an alternative
the plan was moved to the polish village
of pilkowitz this bridge is a more than
100 year old railroad bridge that was
opened by german emperor william ii at
the time and even withstood the second
world war reasonably intact however in
march 2020 local authorities and museums
intervened and prevented the planned
demolition of the structure later
director and producer christopher
macquarie rectified the reports and
claimed that they only wanted to blow up
a small part of the bridge and not the
entire thing either way the project did
cause an international sensation
despite all the back and forth filming
was successfully wrapped up following a
further significant change in the
theatrical release date from 2022
mission impossible 7 dead reckoning part
1 will now hit cinemas on july 14 2023
we hope you enjoyed our original about
the new mission impossible what are your
expectations for the blockbuster and do
you believe the film has still some
surprises left for us feel free to let
us know your thoughts in the comments
[Music]
you